one of the things that we often come
across in our language learning
activities is doubt to go to sort of use
a word or a phrase is this correct and
we doubt ourselves you can't live your
life in doubt if you come to an
intersection and it's your turn to
engage you've got to go you've got drug
is it me is it someone else or whatever
you have to basically function on the
basis of the accumulated experience that
you have with different situations and
it's the same in language trust that you
have accumulated enough experience that
your basic impulse is to use this word
and if you use it wrong you'll quickly
find out because you get a reaction from
the other person so don't doubt yourself
when you're speaking just go for it
whatever that first instinct is just use
that word